this film is so remarkable but what I
think is almost equally remarkable is
how it came to be which we just heard
some Bob Dylan were not for Bob Dylan
this might not have happened in the way
that it did shai as I understand it you
were an amoeba records you were looking
in the Bob Dylan section a documentary
that Alma had done was there you picked
it up you watched it twice that night
you want to pick up the story from there
you betcha yes so I was at Amoeba
Records I was doing some Bob Dylan
research there was a DVD there
it's called Bombay Beach incredible
movie
it said the soundtrack by Beirut and Bob
Dylan I figured wow it's gotta be some
kind of documentary if Scott doesn't
give his movies out his music out often
for all the money in the world so I
think all it's gotta be a tasty DVD here
and I picked this DVD up I go home and
sure enough it's an incredible movie
watched it twice that night instant fan
jump on the Internet
Omaha real calm what's up wizard where
are you
and she's around and she's making a
music video for for this really cool
band and she's like hey you know we
should meet up and we meet up at this
place called the Firefly I'm sure you've
been there and we hang out and we have
similar sensibilities and we're we're
like-minded kindred spirits and she's
like hey come work on this thing with me
in a couple weeks so we work and and
that was the beginning of our creative
life together oma what struck you about
Shia in the initial days and weeks of
that relationship that friendship I
think just his uh I guess his heart and
how much he wanted to pour himself into
art and make something about people and
start to you know make films about
people as opposed to I guess robots and
cars yeah just how passionate he is I
guess and how eloquent he is and funny
yeah all these things that you don't
always know about a person from how they
write
about them and so the beginnings the
premises of the film that we saw here
today came from real-life writings that
you did can you talk a little bit shy
about what you were writing and where
you pictured that going as you were
writing it because I can't imagine a
good time you would have known it would
have become this yeah I was in a mental
institution and I they told me I had
PTSD said the only way out is through we
got a solution for you that solution is
called exposure therapy so we're gonna
go through all these dark chapters your
life we're gonna expose them and write
them down and play them out and so I was
doing this for a couple of weeks and I
had something that that felt like scene
work actually and you know I was in a
really low spot my god is art art love
and God mean the same thing to me I
needed to pray to something I started
feeling really low I had just lost my
platform to express myself
none of y'all were really messing with
me I was quite nuclear at the time and
so I started leaning into this thing and
sent it to my friend who was one of the
only people talking to me at the time
she was working on TV show at that point
and she said hey you know this could be
something special you should stay stay
kick ins can down the hill so I got
really hopeful and and knew that she had
turned down a job and no she's very
tasty I've been sending her auxilary art
stuff for years and she hadn't been she
didn't bite this time she was like hey
you know this could be something and I
thought part of me was thinking oh she's
just trying to keep me afloat and then
another part of me was like maybe she's
right so I kept leaning into it kept
leaning into it leaning into my therapy
leaning into this lean in the Sam
Sheppard plays and out of the
amalgamation of that came this seventy
page conversation in a room with two
characters
went to grammarly made it look cute sent
two back to alma and she said great now
we need to get him out of the room and
when you get out of the room we'll work
on the rest of it so I got out of this
rehab facility what got up with Alma
started talking about how to get them
out of the room kept writing she's like
you need to go see your dad
the ending lies there she was you know I
said double entendre so I hadn't seen my
dad in seven years went to go see him
recorded the whole thing FaceTime and
her recording the conversations from
this get you get a lot of his dialogue
like hey I'm making a movie about your
dad make me look good honey boy
this is all stuff he said that I said
and recorded it all came back and we
started crafting a structure and that
was the process Shia I understand that
you actually spied it was kind of him
and his real-life dad that stood out to
you that made you think this might be
the kid to do this can you just talk
about what don't get it twisted almost a
director it was never like hey here's
what I think it wasn't yeah it was like
you know Alma had found this kid she's
like this is somebody you need to meet
she had really should seen 500 kids by
the time I got to know her so she was
the filtration system
she was grinding for a good two months
before I came in so I knew that this
dude was special because again she he
got the cosign so I'm walking and I'm a
little nervous also you know I know
basically we got to make it work it
wasn't like here's four options it was
like we have two options one is a very
trained actor who's very technically
sound and one is a kid who's never acted
before who's got a very full well of
pain Noah was the trained actor so I'm
quite nervous walking in I'm not very
technically sound I'm the other kid and
and I walk in I hear he's British so
already I'm like knocks not gonna work I
mean dad dad is completely healthy
social wonderful diplomatic I'm like no
[ __ ] way this is this is not gonna
work he points at the door he I said
where's the where's your boy yet he
points at the door I see this kid pacing
outside in the parking lot it's the
first time I think oh [ __ ] okay okay
he's on fire he's bubbling you know he's
out there just pacing and I asked the
dad how long has he been out there about
20 minutes okay there's nobody else in
the room I go outside hey Noah he
doesn't respond
strike two I'm thinking okay
this is something here he's locked in I
go over there and put my hand out he
says hey let's run the scenes so sure
enough we start running the scenes he
knows how to play jazz I go left he goes
left you know we get off the pages he
has the pages these are like 1213 page
scenes he's just which we needed because
we only had 19 days to fill him so you
needed a technical actor who could also
like turn switches knew how to fly his
airplane and so he he was that I put my
hat on his head crowned him King said
hey let's go in here and do this for
Alma we went in Alma was already filming
you know we already making a movie she's
in the parking lot with her phone we
went into the audition room and like you
know basically did it for money you know
we had to do it for the money we had to
like prove it to them that we found our
movie so Lucas is in the room me and
Alma in the room
casting persons in the room and it's
like we've already clicked up we've
already agreed on it and now we got to
like work as a team for the money right
so we make a little tape for the money
tape goes real well and we have our like
18 you know starting five and then
started divvying out pages to all the
actors you know Byron wrote his own
stuff noah wrote his own stuff Lucas
wrote his own stuff just started giving
agency over and like removing myself
from the writer and diving into the
actor and really you know then Alma took
charge and we made a movie one of the
things that really stood out to me is
that in all the films that have ever
been made about addiction addiction in
recovery often gets played a certain way
and the addict is always the bad guy and
there's nothing but bad and there's
never love and there's never humor Byron
can you talk a little bit about bringing
humor into this world of addiction in
recovery
Wow serious I'm like man it's a dramatic
film so I'm have to be serious and then
when I saw it at Sundance and here while
I was laughs and I was like damn gif gif
in a curse you know
so I'm just gonna go with it yeah like
but I'm glad I was able to do what I was
put here to do part of me feel that way
which is bring balance to any project
that I'm a part of so the fact that it
was heavy I was able to be the light in
this film you know I mean naturally and
they gave me the space to do that I
locked in it became that character and
then that character to me befriended
Lucas's character Otis and I knew what
he kind of wanted because in my my
characters mind I've been there before
you know and I saw a part of myself in
Otis so that made us become friends and
we was able to hang and basically I was
able to you know once we confide in one
another
basically let them know that everything
will be okay and like this is a
privilege for us to even be here and go
run with it you know Shia has this been
cathartic for you and not just the
writing of it the making of it the
watching of it the people reacting to
you as they watch it how has it been for
you it's been overwhelming you know I'm
like you know it hasn't landed yet I'm
still kind of levitating I've been
celebrating with my dad every day and
full-faced I'm just giggle at each other
like just stupid faces and my mother is
super proud and I get to see my friends
Beyond and yeah I'm just so I'm very
grateful I'm very grateful to the three
of you for making this film and for
taking the time and for everyone for
showing up today
[Applause]